欢迎回到赵华
上次我有问你一件事
上电机课难
还是上财报课难
那你那时候回答我什么
我忘记了
听起来都很难
学财务的看到数字觉得很难
像我们这些反而看数字
觉得比较简单
看到一些电机的东西
觉得很困难
但今天难还有更难
我必须讲今天的大来宾
他在测试观众的底线
在测试我们两个的上限
测试我们两个专注度
好 现在还欢迎他来的是
知识力科技的创办人
曲建重 曲博
主持人好 各位观众朋友大家好
为什么说在测试我们
今天还不只上电机课
今天要上专利课
今天要看视觉课
因为很多 3D 的东西
但是今天的主题
我们是非常非常的有兴趣
相信观众朋友也很有兴趣
大家知道Intel有做记忆体吗
而且这样的举动
这样的研发
有可能真的让记忆体
擺脱传统的景气循环股
这个议题听起来很赞
过去记忆体都被认为是景气循环
就是几年好几年坏
一直重复
但这一次稍微不一样
是因为人工智慧的需求
所以记忆体的需求量就突然增加
所以确实我认为未来这两三年
记忆体暂时就跟景气循环没关系了
暂时
算句话说
对人工智慧的需求
有一定的需求量
在这个需求量满足之前
这个记忆体确实都在缺货
都在涨价
所以我认为两三年的时间
应该是没有问题
好 我们就要来进入到
今天要来请教曲博的问题
当然前面我们有一些
最近市场上的传闻
例如说KIMI K3
这个中国的AI模型出来
大家觉得
是不是跟当年的Deep Seek一样
你没有会引爆
整个AI市场的担忧
但是你觉得反而记忆体
是会因此受惠的
基本上大家已經記得
千萬不要小看中國大陸
對於軟體開發的能力
所以在人工智慧這一塊
他們其實一直表現得都很好
大家不要忘記
他們是被封鎖的
所以他們是拿不到最先進的東西
先進的晶片
但是中國大陸還是有辦法
把軟體開發出來
而且在實務上用一些評分
發現它的效能是很好的
所以我想上一次是Deep Seek
這一次是Deep Seek 2.0
其实KIMIKI 3
基本上概念是类似
那我们简单看一下什么特别
第一个就是它的参数
这个我们曾经介绍过
这人工智慧的参数就是所谓的权重
它已经到2.8兆
这个已经比之前
都是几千亿几千亿
那很明显就增加
那参数越大通常就是
你在训练的时候需要更多的记忆体
这个是很确定的
所以这是它第一个特色
那另外就是它突破
这个两兆的门槛
使用这个所谓混合专家模型
那简单讲一下
混合专家模型的概念就是
人类在学习东西呢
是我们用一个大脑
一个模型
可以去学习所有的东西
所以我用一个大脑去学钢琴
去学开车
学英文没有问题
可是人工智慧不太一样
因为人工智慧它是
这个一种计算机率的模型
所以你要针对开车
针对下棋
针对弹钢琴
那个其实模型是不一样
所以怎么解决这个问题
它没有办法像人类这么聪明
所以只好搞一个混合模型
把不同的模型整合起来
你今天想要弹钢琴
我就用弹钢琴的模型
你今天想要开车
我用开车的模型
这样精确度才会提高
所以他说有首个
很多个大型参数是集中在一起的
对 这是一个
那另外一个就是这个超长上下文
那这个主要就是在推论的时候呢
我们之前问过的问题
基本上人工智慧必须记下来
我们跟人类聊天的时候
一定会记得
你一个小时之前讲过什么
但是过去的人工智慧
chad GBT
你在跟他聊天的时候
你前面讲的话
他后面就忘了
这个时候
他的行为跟人就不太一样
所以开始我们在推论这个时候
就要求要能够记得
这个所谓上下文
所以基本他就是要记得
这个所谓的长文本
就是你要记得非常非常长
比如说1万个Token的上下文
这是第二个
那这明显可能记忆体的需求量就增加了
那第三个特色就是这个所谓KDA
这个KDA是这一次KIMI K3这一个模型
它自己提出的一个演算法
那传统的人工智慧用的叫Transformer
这个叫变换模型
那它这一次用这个KDA
这一个方法叫做线性注意力机制
那基本就可以来减少它的记忆体消耗量
但是各位不要以为说
因为它减少记忆体消耗
所以记忆体就变小
其实不是这样看
因为我们原来的KVCash
这个所谓建制快取记忆体的容量就不够
所以它现在可以减少记忆体的需求
代表它可以塞进更长的上下纹
所以基本的记忆体需求还是在
但是处理的效能会提升
總之人工智慧未來需求的記憶體
包括動態隨機存取記憶體
DRAM也就是所謂的高頻寬記憶體HBM
或者是快閃記憶體
Flash也就是所謂的SSD固態硬碟機
基本的這個是人工智慧的基礎建設
它的需求都是看好的
曲伯想問一下
聽起來像前面第一個應該是用在HBM對不對
然後第二個是用在SSD
又不太一樣一點
這個又有點複雜
原則上呢
他應該都是要用
動態隨機存取記憶體
因為這些東西
都是要重複一直讀寫
像這個上下文
不同的人聊天
你就要換一次記憶體
要換資料
所以一定是用HBM
但問題是HBM的問題
它的容量比較小
所以業界有一個趨勢
就是想要用快閃記憶體
去取代HBM
那這是另外一個話題了
也就是他們在發展所謂的
高頻寬快閃記憶體
就是HBF
這個我們之前的節目
我記得也介紹過
是
所以
很興趣
HBF 有HBF的特性
至少目前還沒有量產
那是明後年的事
所以暫時目前這一些記憶體
講的大部分都是動態隨機
存取記憶體
就是HBM或是DDR
了解
好
你也很有研究問到重點問到重點好 重點是大家一直講HBM但是沒有想到Intel在開發一個東西叫ZAM這可能大家真的是聽都沒聽過
據說比HBM還厲害
是 那我一直記得兩三年前
當Intel很慘很慘的時候
股價跌到二十幾塊我記得
我每一場在我自己的YouTube上
都會不停的強調
千萬不要小贊這間公司
那Intel它还是有它过去这几十年累积下来的技术实力
所以业内的专业的人都不会小看它
它只是因为良率没有做起来
那良率这件事情坦白说就是在美国外国人来做
就是做不过台湾或者做不过东方人
这个基本上跟他们的技术能力并不是完全相等的
那我们来看一下这一次这个ZAM
就是例行夾角记忆体
这个翻译比较特殊
有什么特色
那我们就要先回头来看到底HBM
它有哪些限制
这个高频关记忆体呢
各位看右边这个图
这个是处理器
那右边这个是记忆体
那各位有没有注意到
高频关记忆体是一个一个晶片
垂直方向这样堆叠起来
然后透过这个所谓的微凸块
把它连接起来
然後再連結到這一個叫細中介版
然後最後再連結到下面這個叫導線載版
ABF
所以這個晶片叫做chip
細中介版叫wafer
導線載版叫subtrait
所以叫做chip on wafer on Subtrait
所以簡稱叫做CoAX
所以這個封裝就是在台積電的CoAX做
但是這種封裝有幾個先天的限制
第一個就是它的結構限制
因為它必須要垂直
這怎麼刪掉
它必須要垂直打1000個或2000個穿孔
那各位想想看穿孔的位置
是不是這個晶片上就不能放記憶體
因為你要留下來給那個金屬導線穿孔
所以這個就是它所謂的結構限制
會佔用這個面積會降低記憶體密度
那第二個特色就是它的熱限制
各位想想看這麼多的晶片垂直疊起來
一直疊起來
那中間這個晶片的熱怎麼散出去
對
它上下通通都是晶片
而且各位知道嗎
HBM4要疊到16層
那這麼多的晶片疊起來
熱散不出去
所以這就是第二個問題
你疊到16層或是更多的時候
中間的晶片會變成熱死去
就是熱傳不出去
那第三個問題就是功耗限制
因為呢
這些晶片在連結的時候
都要透過這些微凸塊
那這些微凸塊本身呢
它電阻就會增加
然後線路拉長之後
它的這個寄生電容跟電感也會增加
那總之呢
這三個限制就造成了HBM本身的限制
那怎麼克服它
所以目前看起來這個HBM
未來還是會越跌越多
但是已經沒有什麼新把戲了
大概就是這樣子
所以這個Intel
它就跟一家軟銀合作
那麼就支援了一家新創公司
那這個公司就發展出這個所謂的
Z型夾角記憶體
所以稱為ZAM
就是Z Angle Memory
那差別在哪呢
剛剛還記得
我們剛剛的HBM是垂直堆疊對不對
還記得嗎
然後細穿孔穿過來的
一兩千個
對對對
你看所以正常的聊天就一定要記得
但是AI如果沒有剛剛說的
記得上下文本
你剛講過的他立刻就忘了
好
那Zangle Memory不一樣
它是水平的方向來做堆疊
下面這個都是系中介板
對
所以回到剛剛這個圖
基本上就是它下面都是系中介板
但是HBM是垂直方向堆疊晶片
但是ZAM是這個方向堆疊晶片
所以各位剛剛看到這個圖
有沒有看到它是這個方向堆疊晶片
往這樣對
那這個方向要怎麼做呢
坦白說我看了這個
Intel的專利
我也是嚇到
我腦洞大開
居然還可以這樣玩
我們來看這個圖
那接下來各位看到的圖呢
都是Intel的專利
好
取出來的圖
專利圖喔
對對對
所以我們今天的這個變成專利課
是
我們來看它怎麼做
還記不記得這個晶片呢
最下面是矽晶片
是
然後呢
把記憶體呢
長在這個地方
這一層
那長完之後呢
正常的狀況呢
剛剛是在做那個矽穿孔
是這個方向對不對
結果它不是
它在上面做出這種
垂直90度的導線
好 那掌完之後呢
如果你把這個晶片轉90度
是就左邊那個圖
什麼意思呢
這是不是矽晶片
就是這個
記憶體是不是在這裡
這個導線層是不是跑到這裡來
所以這個圖就是這個圖
轉90度
這樣可以嗎
轉了90度之後
這些導線的界面是不是跑到下面去了
對吧
對
本來在右邊
對吧
你轉了90度之後這個跑到下面去了
是
OK 就跑到這個地方來了
所以這個地方就變成是這個地方
OK 好
那這個只是在表面喔
那他們腦洞大開
那個可不可以上面玩一個
下面也玩一個
喔
所以你看喔
這是細晶片喔
這是記憶體喔
是
然後呢
上面有90度的導線
然後再做細穿孔
90度的導線
那這樣導線數目就增多了
一樣這個是橫切面喔
然後轉90度
是不是就跑到這個橫切面
是
對不對
對
然後呢這個是矽晶片
這個是記憶體
這個是上層導線
這是背面的導線
這樣有跟上嗎
有
很簡單
他回答得很大聲
有跟上
這還要對空間有概念
這個就是他的專利
那除了這樣
還可不可以有第三種做法呢
有趣喔
這個是細晶片
做記憶體
這個是細晶片做記憶體
做完之後呢
正面對正面
做中間的導線
做完之後再像三明治一樣夾起來
夾起來之後呢
導線就變在中間
記憶體就變上下
對吧
一樣這是不是橫接面
因為這個導線的訊號
是從這個橫接面出來的
有沒有
我為什麼一直要強調橫接面
就是因為所有的電訊號
記憶體在這裡它是從這邊出來的是訊號是從這邊出來的所以這很揭面很重要所以同樣的道理這個訊號從這邊出來這個訊號從這邊出來
這個橫接面是不是很重要
就變在中間
一樣轉90度
橫接面是不是跑到下面去了
對
然後呢
有沒有中間是導線
對
這個是矽晶片
然後這兩個是記憶體
是
所以其實這個圖
就是轉90度就那個的
那你說轉完之後要幹嘛
對啊
所以接下來看
不是 而且第二章跟第三章到底功耗那些的差在哪
而這三章只是他專利告訴大家說
我的導線可以在正面
這是第一章在正面
我導線也可以長正反兩面
這樣導線的數目增加
我也可以夾中間
那記憶體的數量就增加
寫專利一定要包山包海
寫得越大
那這樣別人就會侵犯我專利
所以他把所有的可能都寫下去
很聰明
那轉了90度之後呢
這邊是不是就有一堆導線從這邊要跑出來對不對
那怎麼辦呢
下面再用一個系中介板把導線拉出來
所以各位看下面這個圖
有沒有看到
這個是剛剛的晶片
記憶體還有導線是在這
結果它在下面弄了一個橫方向
一樣晶片
記憶體或者電晶體
然後導線變成水平方向
換句話說
它不是用穿孔接起來
它是用垂直的導線去接水平的導線
先進封裝封起來
而且呢
這個就是下面的這一個晶片
是
這個可能是記憶體
也有可能是電晶體
然後呢有沒有看到
它的記憶體是垂直方向
一片一片這樣疊起來
是
所以訊號是從這個白色的導線
傳到下面這個導線
所以這每一層是不是都可以這樣傳下來
對
所以完全沒有矽穿孔
哦
完全不需要
它完全不做矽穿孔
嗯
這個技術
第一次看到我觉得脑洞大开
但是它难在哪里
它难在你要把两个晶片
这个灰色的部分厚度大概是1微米
我认为大概是10微米以下
大概就1到10微米
我认为大概是这个数字
那我们讲过头发是100微米
所以1微米是细菌的大小
换句话说你要把两个晶片夹角90度
这边的导线跟这边的导线这样
在先进封装的时候
要对得很准
这个边要对得很准
这件事情没有那么容易
所以我认为这个将来
会面临的是制造的问题
就是你怎么把它良率做起来
但是以整体它的这个概念
设计是有创意的
是很有创意
那这样子就避免了细穿孔
也不会跌16层
然后那个穿孔要穿16层
穿16层其实那个
良率也有问题
困难度很高
所以最后呢
你看到的会长这样子
有没有看到这是处理器
然后这个记忆体
有没有注意它不是刚刚HBM这样垂直堆
它变成水平堆
然后这个是下面那一个
这个是上面的
那这样我是不是可以在处理器旁边呢
就堆很多的这个记忆体
有没有
所以它可以让高频宽记忆体的容量增加
目前的高频宽记忆体
大概就是做到几百GB左右
通常就是目前大概一两百
2、300GB
但是用这个方法
根据这个Intel的说法
可以做到10倍
所以容量可以大幅增加
10倍
那当然那个可能是比较高的数字
但我觉得做个3、5倍
应该是没有问题
就解决掉容量不足的问题
也可以解决掉
刚刚所谓热死区的问题
它的散热会比较好的原因
是因为它的所有的导线
是这个方向
所以热会沿着这个导线散出去
換句話說就是剛剛這個圖
它的這一個熱會沿著這個方向散出去
不像那個垂直方向堆疊
那個熱矽晶片不容易散熱
金屬容易散熱
所以導線比較容易散熱
概念上大概是這樣
那從側面看就會變這樣
這是處理器
這個是下面那個晶片
然後這個是垂直的那個記憶體
所以一個底晶片就可以堆好幾個垂直的記憶體
然後堆在處理器旁邊
這個是系中介板
這個是導線載板
所以它的概念只是把記憶體從水平方向
垂直方向堆變成水平方向堆
那這樣子就可以增加記憶體的容量
跟散熱的特性
大概是這樣
在出現這張圖之前
想要請教的當然是
Intel of Flavie發展這個專利
有量产的能力了吗
好 那这个是到目前为止
叫例行夹角记忆体
ZenMemory基本的
它是跟这个日本的公司合作
那有没有量产的专利就要看
能力就要看明后年
因为这个已经是在
样品制作的阶段了
所以我想这个
我们可以再观察明后年
这个记忆体有没有一些突破
但总之呢
以原理来看
我觉得这个原理是可以运作的
那唯一的困难应该是良率怎么做高
是
因为为什么会这么问
是记忆体很奇妙
如果说它可以顺利量产
大家搞不好很吓到
会觉得说这东西会取代HBM
可能记忆体的价格就会摔下来之类的
我认为因为它还是动态随机存取记忆体
所以即使这个方法可行
DRAIN的价格也不会摔下来
但是会不会取代HBM
會 會至少取代一部分
所以就看它是不是可以順利的量產
那我想這個當然
整個記憶體產業搞不好又會有些不同
如果它可行
那以前Intel根本就被遺忘了
我在電視機前的觀眾
大部分都不知道Intel做記憶體
事實上Intel一直都有在做記憶體
我還曾經那個Intel的
我在德州一切的時候
Intel做記憶體部門的那個
主管還來拜訪過我們
就是想要推Intel的記憶體
它一直有在做
只是跟這個海力士三星美光比起來
它的進度還有技術能力是不一樣的
所以一直都沒有辦法競爭
除了這個之外還有一個更絕的
他們後來又發另外一個專利
但是這個部分目前還在專利的部分
所以可不可行不知道
坦白說這個記憶體稱為P次跨P次記憶體叫Cross Batch Memory所以他把它取名叫XBM你看又有新東西對 好多BM對 那這個
這一篇專利
基本我看完了
但是它完全滿足專利撰寫的三大特徵
這個可能觀眾朋友不知道
我們順便介紹一下
專利撰寫有三大特徵
一定要做到
代表你這個專利寫得棒
是
第一個就是
找不到
为什么
因为要让竞争对手找不到
这样竞争对手才会误采我的专利
到时候我就可以告他
是
找不到
第二个特色就是看不懂
你今天竞争对手
就算找到我的专利了
你也看不懂
成功了成功了
所以这一篇完全满足
因为坦白说我看不懂
那第三个特色就是绕不开
什么意思呢
就是你就算找到了
你就算看懂了
你也绕不开我这个专利
所以你要做的时候很抱歉
你一定会侵犯我的专利
是
所以各位记得
专利撰写的三大特色
找不到
看不懂
绕不开
是
那他满足了这三大特色
那虽然看不懂啊
但是呢
我大概可以猜出
他想要做什么
是
那首先呢
他这一个跟刚刚不一样
刚刚那个是先进封装
所以他改良的只是封装的方式
他的记忆体还是DRAM
所以基本上
就是你刚刚讲的
他就算成功量产
DRAM的需求也不会变
因为他还是DRAM
但这个就不是了
它这个电晶体改成用所谓的薄膜电晶体
所以薄膜电晶体通常会取代我们讲的一般的电晶体
是因为它长不出单晶
所以它特别这边有提到
它的结构还是一个电晶体一个电容
这跟DRAM是一样的
但是它把这个储存单元移到后段制程
你们现在看到这个文字是它的专利里面写的
那什么叫移到后段制程
我们的元件是在锡晶片上先长电晶体
那个叫前段制程
然后再长所谓的多层导线
那个叫后段制程
那多层导线长完呢
它的意思是要把储存单元移到后段制程的上面
也就是电晶体的上方
那看起来它应该是先做金属导线
再做电晶体
我猜它是这个意思
所以才会用所谓的薄膜电晶体
它虽然是记忆体堆叠
但是它的速度基本要达到
每秒钟32Gigatransfer
就是传送速度
没关系只要记得它的速度够快
但是重点是它透过Intel自己的标准
叫做UCI-E
这个叫做通用小晶片互联快捷
这是Intel提出来的标准
但是还有其他厂商一起参与
所以它是一个大家共用的标准
那它的意思就是说
用新形态的记忆体
配上UCIE这种通讯界面
那么可以让HBM的价格降下来
所以关键是什么呢
关键就是它的速度
虽然没有比HBM快
但是它的价格比HDM低
那这个就是它希望将来有机会
跟这个HBM竞争的另外一个武器
大概是这样
好 它如果真的能够进入到量产的地步
就是杀手机的东西了
听起来是这样
但是那个是因为只有专益
所以我觉得听过就好
但是这边就来到
我们比较庸俗的地方了
我们一直在讲Intel
没有想到这个鸭子滑水
在记忆体的部分
其实它有想要当霸主的想法
因为前面可能看得懂DAM
是可能快要量产了
后面刚刚讲到的这个XBM
它有可能会制定规格
和新的记忆体的用法
那Intel在台厂的部分
其實還是有一些相關的合作廠商
是有可能在這個
所謂先從ZAM開始好了
有可能在這個部分合作嗎
譬如說像各位說
聯電跟Intel一直有合作
就是先進制
聯電
等於是Intel把一些
他覺得可以想要授權出去
那他管工廠可能也沒有聯電厲害
可能就交給他
那當然有IC設計相關的公司
那另外這個
剛剛講的ZAM的記憶體
其實這個利機電跟艾普
是有跟他們合作的
但是細節就是說將來有誰量產
沒有相關的資料
所以我不確定將來intel是要自己生產
還是想要委外給別人代工
這目前還不知道
當然相關的封裝廠一定有
那載板廠
各位剛剛看到所有的記憶體
最下面都是載板
所以我想對台灣來說
就算intel順利量產
ZAM或者XEM
其實台灣相關的供應鏈
應該都還是可以帶來一些傷心
好 因為我們本來都會把Intel
當作是台藝店的競爭對手
但是也不要忽略
其實台廠供應內有很多
是跟Intel在合作的
因為我們之前常常講到
台灣的機體都在DDR的範圍內
但是如果透過跟Intel的合作
也許就可以進階到更高階的
不管是HBM或是VAM這樣的商品
我覺得這個應該也是
大家在產業提升上
很好的一個進步
好 那當然最後其實
我們最後這一題
曲博已經在一開始就有講了
AI的需求是会让记忆体跳脱景气循环
重点是要发展刚刚讲的高阶商品
对 就是未来这两三年
因为AI的需求
所以记忆体确实已经不会是像以前一样循环了
那至于说三五年以后会不会
我觉得这件事情就回到
我每次来节目都一直反复讲的
人工智慧一本正经胡说八道
这问题有没有解决
如果有解决
那人工智慧的需求还会持续成长
那如果一直没办法解决
那我觉得这些客户很可能就会放慢投资脚步
那这个时候或许整个半导体的状况
又会稍微不一样
我个人觉得有改善
就是一本正经胡说八道这件事情
对
有改善
但是现在觉得有改善
是因为他们用了一个方法
叫做RAG
检索增强深层
那这个方法其实有点偷吃步
简单的说
它让你觉得它正确率提高了
但是大家要记得就是
工程的東西是這樣
前面80分要提高是容易的
後面那20分要提高是困難的
是 完全理解
所以關鍵在最後那時候
好 今天非常謝謝曲伯來
既然幫我們上的是一堂專利課
我不曉得觀眾朋友有沒有聽懂
但我們聽起來是覺得曲伯很厲害
因為剛剛我們一開始在看圖的時候
是覺得應該是完全聽不懂
可是你講完之後就覺得
好像有感
刺懂 非懂
至少在這個10分鐘不會忘記
但下一次取過來
我覺得我不是那麼確定了
而剛剛講到的這些配合常常